merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames messieurs je
vous remercie de nous donner
l'opportunité de nous exprimer devant
vous bande de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques sur un phénomène inédit
inattendu celui de la corrosion sous
contrainte des tuyauteries des circuits
auxiliaires du circuit primaire
phénomène qui aujourd'hui vous le savez
perturbe le fonctionnement de notre parc
nucléaire mon exposé nécessairement un
peu technique aura pour objectif de
retracer les différentes étapes qui nous
ont permis de comprendre le phénomène et
bien sûr de le traiter alors tout
d'abord un rapide historique c'est à
l'automne 2021 lors de la visite
décennale du réacteur de civo 1 dans la
Vienne qu'à l'occasion de contrôle
réaliser dans le cadre de cette arrêt
programmée nous découvrons des
indications dans les indications c'est
un signal anormal atypique sur des
portions de tuyauterie des circuits
auxiliaires du circuit primaire sur le
circuit d'injection de sécurité risques
c'est un circuit de sauvegarde qui est à
l'arrêt en fonctionnement normal mais
bien sûr qui a pour fonction d'injecter
de l'eau dans la cuve du réacteur en cas
d'accident par exemple en cas de brèche
dans circuit primaire c'est donc un
circuit très important pour la sûreté du
réacteur la portion de tuyauterie ou
sont détectés ces indications et celle
qui est directement connectée au circuit
primaire avant le premier organisme
d'isolement c'est-à-dire avant la
première vanne de ce circuit
quelques ordres de grandeur pour vous
éclairer sur les dimensions de ces
tuyauterie elles font environ 30 cm de
diamètre et l'épaisseur du métal est de
3 cm et la longueur totale des portions
de circuit est de en moyenne d'une
dizaine de mètres
donc lors de chaque visite des Sénats
sur tous les réacteurs du parc nucléaire
nous effectuons des contrôles sur ces
tuyauteries afin d'y rechercher
d'éventuelles défauts et notamment le
phénomène dit de fatigue thermique la
fatigue thermique c'est un mécanisme
d'endommagement induit par des
fluctuations répétitives de la
température liée par exemple à la
présence de tourbillons d'eau chaude à
l'entrée du circuit pour rechercher ce
type de défaut nous effectuons des
contrôles par ultrason c'est-à-dire au
moyen d'un appareil qui envoie des ondes
sonores dans la tuyauterie et c'est par
la lecture et l'analyse complexe de les
cours envoyés c'est un signal lu sur un
écran que nous pouvons déterminer s'il y
a des faux autrement dit une fissure
dans le métal
fin 2021
j'y reviens nous détectons par cet
appareil à ultrasons des indications sur
les tuyauteries de civo 1
mais qui clairement ne correspondent pas
de la fatigue thermique nous découpons
ces portions de tuyauterie pour les
remplacer et les expertiser dans notre
laboratoire holiday à chinois et donc
c'est là à notre grande surprise que
nous découvrons qui ne s'agit pas de
fissures justement initiée par la
fatigue thermique mais bien par de la
corrosion sous contrainte et il s'agit
de fissures de taille significative
puisqu'elle font 5 à 6 mm de profondeur
sur toute la circonférence de la
tuyauterie elles se sont développées
dans le métal à proximité des soudures
pas dans les soudures mais à proximité
des soudures
alors un petit arrêt sur image momentané
sur la corrosion sous contrainte la
corrosion sous contrainte c'est une
fissuration progressive qui est fondée
sur une interaction entre un matériau
ici un AC inoxydable assez classique dit
316L un environnement là c'est l'eau qui
passe dans ce tuyau qui a évidemment des
composants chimiques du bord du lithium
de l'hydrogène et une sollicitation
mécanique qui peut provenir soit de
contraintes résiduelles du soudage
initial soit de sollicitations mécanique
lors du fonctionnement même de ce
circuit
ce phénomène est donc bien le résultat
d'interactions complexe entre ces trois
dimensions avec des paramètres qui
influent plus ou moins nous avons déjà
rencontré à la fin des années 90 des
premiers cas de fissuration par CSC
d'acier inoxydable mais ces cas étaient
liés en général à une pollution qui
avait été
identifiée lors des expertises et bien
sûr un recensement alors par zone a été
effectué sur la base des connaissances
de l'époque et aucun risque d'apparition
de corrosion sous contrainte n'a alors
été identifiée sur les lignes
auxiliaires dont les lignes riches dont
je parle à l'instant entre la connexion
sur le circuit primaire et la première
vanne d'où le caractère inattendu de ce
que l'on découvre à Civaux
la seule situation similaire que nous
ayons repéré dans le monde entier se
trouve au Japon dans la centrale Dohy
réacteur douille 3 et vu en 2020 avec la
détection de corrosion sous contrainte
sur une tuyauterie en milieu primaire
effectivement sur un acier inoxydable
assez proche de l'acier dont nous
parlons à Civaux alors j'y reviens les
résultats des contrôles effectués à
Civaux et la nature des défauts relevés
nous conduisent alors à mettre
immédiatement à l'arrêt le jumeau le
réacteur de Civaux 2 pour y réaliser les
mêmes contrôles nous y détectons des
défauts similaires et donc dans la
foulée à titre de précaution nous
mettons également à l'arrêt les deux
autres réacteurs du même palier dit M4
et deux réacteurs de chaud dans les
Ardennes vous le savez la sûreté AEDF
est une prière était absolue n'y est
donc pas de débat entre nous nous devons
arrêter les réacteurs dans lesquels la
corrosion sous contrainte est identifiée
un autre événement survient alors en
parallèle sur le réacteur de panli 1 lui
aussi en visite décennale au cours des
contrôles programmés lors de cet arrêt
une indication est relevée à nouveau sur
une tuyauterie d'injection de sécurité
ris les expertises réalisent dans la
foulée montrent qu'il s'agit également
de corrosion selon Trump nous comprenons
alors que ce n'est pas seulement le
palier N4 qui est concerné mais
l'ensemble du palier du parc nucléaire
pardon qui est potentiellement concerné
nous sommes donc bien confrontés à un
défaut générique
la réglementation française est claire
et notamment l'arrêté du 10 novembre
1999 relatif à la surveillance de
l'exploitation du circuit primaire
principal de nos réacteurs dans une
telle situation le maintien en service
de défaut de cette nature ne peut se
faire qu'après une instruction technique
longue et approfondie et il nous est
apparu que seul la réparation des
défauts rencontrés étaient à privilégier
pour assurer un retour rapide des
réacteurs sur le réseau nous avons
établi alors une stratégie de contrôle
qui vise à avoir aussi rapidement
possible une vision précise de l'état de
notre parc une stratégie qui est basée
sur deux piliers on a à la fois défini
des réacteurs témoins par palier et puis
surtout effectuer une relecture a
posteriori de l'ensemble des contrôles
réalisés ces 10 dernières années sur
l'ensemble des réacteurs du parc
suite à ces travaux ce sont cette
réacteurs supplémentaires qui vont être
mises à l'arrêt en complément des 4 N4
et de Pandi 1 nous retrouvons ici les 12
réacteurs dont vous avez tous entendu
parler au cours du premier semestre 2022
en raison de ce problème nous équipes
ont du réaliser ces contrôles par
ultrasons seuls dispose disponible à
l'époque qui a des limites comme je vous
l'ai dit puisqu'il n'est pas prévu pour
trouver de la corrosion sous contrainte
mais bien de la de la fatigue thermique
il n'est donc malheureusement pas à
mesure de préciser la nature la
profondeur des indications relevées et
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix que de procéder à des
découpes de portions tuyauterie qui sont
alors déposées pour être transférées à
Chinon dans le laboratoire du Guidec ce
sont donc de nombreux chantiers de
grande ampleur qui commence au total sur
le premier semestre 2022 ce sont 115
soudures différentes qui ont été
expertisé avec des équipements de
laboratoire de haute technologie
230 échantillons métallographiques ont
été analysés avec des microscopes de
grandes précisions
alors c'est l'ensemble de ce travail
d'expertise
titanesque qui nous permet d'avoir
aujourd'hui une relative bonne
compréhension du phénomène et notamment
de pouvoir raisonnablement affirmé
premier point le caractère prépondérant
d'apparition de la CSC est la géométrie
des lignes des circuits auxiliaires
parce qu'elles détermine le niveau de
contraintes rencontré dans les
tuyauteries
deuxième point les réacteurs de 900 MW
c'est-à-dire 32 réacteurs et les
réacteurs de 1300 MW du palier P4
c'est-à-dire 8 réacteurs sont peu ou
très peu sensibles à la corrosion sous
contrainte
en revanche c'est le troisième point les
réacteurs de 1300 mégawatts de type P
prime 4 c'est-à-dire 12 réacteurs et les
réacteurs N4 sont sensibles ou fortement
sensibles à l'apparition de la corrosion
sous contrainte il ressort également de
nos analyses que la zone de tuyauterie
dans laquelle le phénomène apparaît est
délimité par une soudure au-delà de
laquelle la corrosion ne se développe
plus tous ces éléments combinés avec des
analyses de sûreté et des calculs de
tenues mécaniques des tuyauteries nous
ont permis de présenter à l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire le 13 juillet dernier
un dossier complet comprenant à la fois
notre analyse ainsi qu'une stratégie de
contrôle et de réparation pour
l'ensemble de nos réacteurs je laisserai
bien entendu le président de la SN
s'exprimait sur cette stratégie
alors par rapport à votre question sur
le sénateur Longuet où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
sur les douze réacteurs 10 on fait ou
font l'objet de réparation des circuits
qui ont été déposés
alors deux d'entre eux évidemment sur
les 12 mérite un petit commentaire tout
d'abord flamant vilain ou une opération
majeure de remplacement de général de
générations
de générateur de vapeur est en cours et
les deux opérations ne peuvent pas être
menées de concert donc nous y viendrons
plus tard nous espérons comme il s'agit
d'un réacteur du palier P4 ne pas
découvrir de corrosion sur ces
tuyauterie et puis buge 3 qui est un
réacteur du palier 900 MW donc moins
sensible au phénomène de corrosion ou
suite notamment aux résultats des
expertises de budget 4 et de Fessenheim
qui nous montrait aucune trace de
corrosion sous contrainte nous avons
décidé avec l'accord de la SN de ne pas
procéder à des écoutes d'aller découpes
pour expertise donc je reviens aux 10
chantiers de réparation 6 sont
aujourd'hui terminés permettant le
retour de ces réacteurs sur le réseau
pour l'hiver qui vient
un autre chantier à panlien devrait se
terminer courant novembre et notre
objectif qui reste atteignable et que
les trois derniers chantés savoir les
deux réacteurs de chaud et le réacteur
de Civaux soit terminé d'ici la fin de
l'année il convient de noter un qu'à la
fin d'un chantier CSC il peut rester un
certain nombre d'activités à réaliser de
plus ou moins grande ampleur
un point qui n'est pas de détail sur ces
réparations puisque la question nous est
souvent posée nos procédés sont basés
sur des modes opératoires semblables à
ceux utilisés à l'origine principalement
parce que ces procédés ont alors fait
l'objet d'une qualification et que
évidemment en si peu de temps il serait
impossible de qualifier de nouveaux
procédés néanmoins nous apportons des
améliorations sensibles et surtout nous
allons contribuer à travailler dans ce
sens là la bonne réalisation de ces
chantiers et le résultat d'une
mobilisation de plusieurs partenaires
industriels qui sont engagés à nos côtés
depuis l'origine je voudrais ici les
remercier il s'agit de Monteiro et son
partenaire honnête qui ont fait un
travail remarquable à civo1 à Tricastin
3 et qui sont aujourd'hui concentrés sur
si vos deux et chaud deux
Endel qui a rapidement terminé un
premier chantier à Chinon B3 et qui est
aujourd'hui mobilisée à panli 1 et par
ailleurs avec si j'ai dit ont été tout à
fait remarquable à cattom 4 enfin les
deux chaudies framatum et Westinghouse
qui sont présents sur les chantiers de
bugecat Flamanville 2 et showin il nous
apporte leur expertise technique ainsi
qu'une dimension internationale a été
beaucoup évoquée avec la sollicitation
de soudeur venus notamment d'Amérique du
Nord des industriels évidemment que
j'aurais souhaité plus nombreux ou avec
des ressources plus importantes non
seulement pour pouvoir aller plus vite
sur ces chantiers mais aussi pour des
questions de radioprotection afin de
minimiser la dosimétrie intégrée par
ceux qui travaillent sur ces chantiers
dans le respect de la réglementation
bien entendu
nous sommes en passe grâce à eux de
tenir notre objectif de remettre ses
réacteurs sur le réseau pour le prochain
hiver par ailleurs je tiens à souligner
que dès le début de l'année 2022 nous
avons mobilisé des fondeurs et des
forgerons italiens avec qui nous avions
l'habitude de travailler dans le cadre
du programme grand carnage cette
mobilisation a été très efficace puis au
bout de 6 mois nous avons eu toutes les
pièces de rechange pour réaliser les
travaux de réparation programmées
cette anticipation des besoins dès le
début de la crise a été un élément clé
de sa résolution au vu de l'association
actuelle nous sommes encore en mesure je
le répète de respecter les objectifs
fixés par le responsable d'équilibre RTE
pour le prochain hiver
voilà pour l'urgence un petit mot de ce
qui vient maintenant puisque l'une de
vos questions monsieur le sénateur
Longuet était celle de la durée de la
perspective le dossier n'est pas clos
c'est évident en premier lieu et
conformément à l'engagement que nous
avons pris vis-à-vis de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire nous allons procéder à
des contrôles sur l'ensemble des
réacteurs les plus sensibles donc le
palier de paix prime 4 et ces contrôles
sont déjà engagés sur quatre mains
golfechin et panli 2 et ils le seront
sur les autres réacteurs l'année
prochaine bien sûr et en fonction des
résultats de ces contrôles nous
procéderons ou non à des réparations
j'en profite pour faire une incise sur
les moyens de contrôle je vous l'ai dit
il y a quelques minutes jusqu'ici on
avait un moyen qui était lié à une autre
recherche la fatigue thermique il a
fallu développer un nouveau dispositif
c'est une vraie prouesse que d'avoir
développé en moins d'un an
une nouvelle technique de contrôle par
ultrason qui est déjà de très grande
qualité puisque une capacité de sonder
justement ces 3 cm de d'épaisseur de
métal je tiens là aussi à saluer tous
ceux qui ont travaillé sur cet outil qui
n'est pas encore parfait mais dont on
pense pouvoir vraiment disposer
totalement à partir du début de l'année
prochaine et donc nous éviter des
découpes complémentaires
par ailleurs même si nous avons à ce
stade une compréhension assez fine du
phénomène nous sommes également
conscients qui restent encore beaucoup
d'efforts de R&D amener pour décrypter
tous ces mécanismes complexes pour nous
aider
pour nous éclairer nous avons réuni au
début du mois d'octobre 15 experts
venant du monde entier des experts de
métallurgie nous leur avons transmis de
nombreux documents sous confidentialité
bien évidemment
nous avons été auditionnés les uns et
les autres et il
prit un certain nombre de
recommandations qui vont nous être très
utile
nous avons évidemment interrogé sur le
bien fondé de notre analyse et de façon
unanime ils ont dit partager nos
conclusions mais ils nous ont également
demandé d'approfondir certains sujets
c'est ce que j'évoquais il s'agit par
exemple de la température du circuit qui
sans doute un facteur important mais
également du taux d'oxygène dans ces
mêmes circuits sujets pour lesquels nous
allons lancer des campagnes de mesures
les experts ont également donné un avis
favorable sur le nouveau dispositif de
contrôle ultrasonor que j'évoquais à
l'instant et qui va être très important
enfin tout en soulignant le bien-fondé
des remplacements de tuyauterie à
l'identique parce que c'était des styles
la meilleure solution pour amener les
tranches le plus vite possible
pour autant ils ont indiqué que dans
leur pays pour certains des solutions de
type pardon de l'anglicisme mais il est
pas vraiment de traduction française
d'overley était utilisé en fait c'est un
dispositif qui consiste en l'ajout à
l'extérieur de la tuyauterie d'un
dispositif métallique sous des sur la
tuyauterie elle-même à l'endroit une
fissure est présente c'est un dispositif
qualifié selon les codes et normes
américaines dit asmé eDF va examiner
bien sûr la pertinence de ce type de
solution et engagé un dialogue avec la
SN sur le sujet
oui alors le mot qui va beaucoup
déplaire aux spécialistes qui est
souvent utilisé ces manchonnage validé
voyez c'est l'idée du manchon qui vient
voilà mais l'idée c'est bien d'ajouter
une couche complémentaire pour couvrir
la fissure et la protéger momentanément
donc après cette phase d'urgence nous
passons donc comme je vous le disais à
l'instant à une seconde phase qui vise à
réaliser des contrôles et des actions de
recherche de plus long terme c'est un
programme de plusieurs années qui
s'ouvrent devant nous
certes les impacts sur la production
devraient être de plus en plus faibles
au fil des mois heureusement mais il va
encore mobiliser beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup de monde en conclusion je
souhaiterais vous faire part de trois
éléments qui ont été un fil directeur
pour nous tout au long de l'année qui
vient de s'écouler le premier qui ne
vous surprendra pas la sûreté nucléaire
a été et demeurera notre priorité
absolue à aucun moment nous n'avons
transigé avec la sûreté nous avons
parfois dû prendre des décisions
difficiles comme de mettre à la raie
certains réacteurs en plein hiver mais
nous devions le faire et ce principe qui
dit que la sûreté nucléaire est notre
priorité absolue nous l'avons mis en
application
corollaire du point précédent c'est la
relation bien sûr avec l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire une relation qui doit
être de qualité fondée sur la confiance
le dialogue et une transparence
irréprochable nous nous sommes appliqués
là aussi à respecter ses principes tout
au long de la crise parce que c'est un
élément indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de l'industrie nucléaire
civile
enfin
troisième point concerne notre volonté
constante de partager avec la SN de
disposer aussi rapidement que possible
d'un état de situation précis d'où les
115 expertises et tout ce que je viens
de vous décrire je voudrais à nouveau
remercier tous les agents d'EDF et tous
les salariés de nos entreprises
partenaires pour leur mobilisation tout
au long de cette année nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train de sortir peu à peu
de la crise pour apporter au pays
l'électricité dont il a besoin non
seulement pour l'hiver mais aussi pour
les prochaines saisons Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires vous
pourrez toujours compter sur EDF et ses
agents pour assurer cette belle et
grande mission d'intérêt général quel
service public de l'électricité avec
Etienne Duteil directeur du parc
nucléaire Hubert catalet qui est
derrière moi directeur du projet
corrosion sous contrainte nous sommes
bien sûr à votre entière disposition
pour répondre à vos questions merci de
votre attention
bien je vous remercie pour votre propos
nous avons bien compris que votre
priorité absolue comme vous l'avez dit
était la Sûreté Nucléaire je laisse donc
la parole au président Bernard torosuc
de
son analyse sur cette situation et
notamment sur les décisions qui ont pu
être prises par l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le vice-président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires tout
d'abord merci de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour cette réunion de lopex
consacrée à la corrosion sous contrainte
qui a été découverte sur le parc du
clair de DF je suis accompagné d'Olivier
gusta directeur général de la SN et d'un
certain nombre de représentants de la SN
qui pourront également répondre aux
questions qui seront posées par les
membres de l'OPEX alors sans reprendre
le propos introductif de Cédric
Lewandowski qui est très complet je
voudrais bannière générale et de manière
liminaire insistée sur quatre points
alors le premier point c'est que tout
d'abord la corrosion sous contrainte et
je dirais pour être plus précis la
fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte est un sujet sérieux qui a
été traité sérieusement par EDF
alors c'est un sujet sérieux d'abord
parce que
la fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte comporte de réels en jeu de
sûreté dès lors que elle peut conduire à
une brèche sur un circuit auxiliaire
directement connecté au circuit primaire
sans possibilité de l'isoler comme ça a
été rappelé donc c'est sérieux en
matière de sûreté en cas de brèche
primaire donc s'il y avait une rupture
de ces circuits auxiliaires nous serions
clairement dans une situation
accidentelle
une texture une situation accidentelle
avec des dommages en installation et
potentiellement une perte durable du
réacteur éventuellement même avec des
rejets à l'extérieur modérés mais
existants
donc il s'agit absolument pas de
minimiser l'impact d'un tel événement la
situation c'est une situation sérieuse
la fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte est un sujet sérieux parce
que il est maintenant clairement
générique sur les réacteurs les quatre
réacteurs du pallier N4 et
potentiellement générique sur les 12
réacteurs du palier pprine 4 comme
l'indiqué Cédric lors de ski
et enfin les fissurations de corrosion
sous contrainte qui ont été découvertes
ne sont pas négligeables elles sont
potentiellement évolutives au sein de
l'épaisseur et peuvent atteindre
plusieurs millimètres des valeurs ont
été données je les confirme ça peut
atteindre jusqu'au quart de l'épaisseur
avec peu de marge par rapport à la
taille du défaut critique qui pourrait
entraîner une rupture de la canalisation
en cas de déclenchement de déclenchement
pardon du circuit d'injection de
sécurité donc c'est un sujet sérieux
si la fissuration par corrosion sous
contrainte et c'est un sujet sérieux
c'est aussi un sujet difficile à traiter
il s'agit d'une fissuration inattendue
vu le type de matériaux qui était
utilisé pour fabriquer ces circuits et à
ce stade inédite je le confirme à cet
ampleur sur le parc mondial des
réacteurs à eau sous pression et donc
les exploitants EDF ne disposaient
d'aucun retour d'expérience
internationale pouvant accélérer le
traitement de ce phénomène il s'agit
d'une fissuration difficile à détecter
car se propageant d'une certaine manière
en ligne brisée ce n'est pas une
fissuration de type fatigue thermique en
ligne droite elle se propage en ligne
brisée en suivant les joints du métal et
donc les dispositifs de contrôle non
destructif qui étaient disponibles au
moment de la découverte de cet événement
qui n'était pas adapté à la
caractérisation de ce type de
fissuration ne permettez pas de
connaître exactement la taille de cette
fissuration
et enfin il s'agit d'un sujet difficile
à traiter car il nécessite des
interventions pour le contrôle et la
réparation en milieu dosant proche du
circuit primaire principal ce qui impose
des protections et une durée limitée
d'intervention pour les travailleurs
s'il s'agit d'un sujet sérieux et
difficile c'est aussi un sujet qui a été
traité très sérieusement par EDF je
confirme tout à fait ce qui a été dit
par Cédric Lewandowski à l'instant sur
la mobilisation de la totalité des
équipes d'EDF et des prestataires pour
pouvoir mieux approfondir la
connaissance de la situation et prendre
des mesures de prudence dans
l'incapacité que nous étions au
démarrage de cet événement de
caractériser la taille des fissurations
ces équipes ont travaillé en étroite
relation avec la direction des
équipements sous pression de la SN qui
disposent d'une expertise reconnue sur
ces sujets et avec la direction des
centrales nucléaires de la SN avec
l'appui technique de l'IRSN que je tiens
à remercier
deuxième point
EDF a déployé un plan d'investigation
conséquent très rapidement qui lui a
permis de proposer une stratégie
priorisée de contrôle et de réparation
cette stratégie a été approuvée par la
scène fin juillet elle doit désormais
être mise en œuvre
comme la décrit Cédric le vent de ski le
premier semestre 2022 a été consacré à
la mise en oeuvre d'un plan
d'investigation conséquent proposé par
EDF et je n'y retiendrai pas ce plan
basé sur des découpes et des expertises
ainsi que sur des justifications de
sûreté a permis de dégager une vue plus
complète de l'état du parc et des enjeux
de sûreté ce plan d'investigation était
indispensable pour comprendre le
phénomène
identifier les zones des réacteurs les
plus concernés et définir une stratégie
de contrôle priorisé la SN a estimé que
ce plan d'investigation était pertinent
comme cela a été indiqué les
investigations menées ont permis
d'identifier la géométrie des
tuyauteries et les contraintes
mécaniques comme étant les principaux
facteurs d'influence de l'apparition des
fissures de corrosion sous contrainte
les soudures réalisées avec de fortes
énergies de soudage et sans harasage
constituent également un facteur
aggravant en ce qui concerne le
développement de ces fissurations sous
contrainte et donc la qualité des
soudures notamment celles qui seront
mises en oeuvre pour réparer les
circuits même si les baux d'opératoires
sont identiques à se utiliser à la
construction initiale doit être
particulièrement soigné pour éviter la
réapparition de le plus possible de ce
type de fissuration
ce plan d'investigation a permis
d'identifier comme cela a été dit les
réacteurs N4 et les réacteurs du 13100
du palier Pinka comme étant les plus
sollicités il y a donc au total 16
réacteurs 4 N4 plus 12 B prime 4 qui
sont prioritaires
cette réacteur parmi les 16 étaient
couverts par le plan d'investigation def
donc fait l'objet de découpe ou
d'investigation pour pouvoir connaître
l'état de ces de ces circuits et
éventuellement engager des réparations 7
3 sont en cours de contrôle par rapport
à la stratégie qui a été proposée par
EDF et six réacteurs reste encore à
contrôler d'ici
mi-2023 au plus tard c'est l'application
de la stratégie proposée par EDF qui a
été validé par l'ASL une priorisation
dans les opérations de contrôle d'ici
2023 sur les 16 réacteurs qui sont
considérés comme étant les plus
sensibles
nous avons estimé que cette stratégie
proposée par EDF est état propriétaire
compte tenu à la fois des connaissances
acquises sur le phénomène et des enjeux
de sûreté qui était associés les
contrôles seront réalisés avec un
nouveau procédé non destructif par
ultrasons qui pour la première fois
permettra de caractériser la taille des
défauts sans savoir besoin de procéder à
des découpes et donc à des réparations
les premiers résultats de développement
de cette nouvelle méthode de contrôle
sont encourageant mais il reste encore à
consolider et cette technique de
contrôle devra être qualifiée
une attention particulière devra être
portée au soudure qui ont été réparés au
moment de la construction initiale nous
avons constaté au fur et à mesure des
investigations qui ont été menées des
expertises que les soudures qui ont été
réparés intruisent des champs de
contraintes différentes approximité de
soudure et peuvent être à l'origine de
développement plus rapide de corrosion
sous contrat donc toutes les soudures
qui ont été réparées au moment de la
construction d'origine devront être
contrôlés par la nouvelle technique de
contrôle en fonction des résultats qui
seront obtenus la caractérisation de ces
contrôles sur les 16 réacteurs avec
toutes les soudures réparées l'ASN
pourrait être amenée à demander soit la
remise en état des circuits affectés si
la taille des fissurations est
importante soit d'accepter la remise en
état de manière différée après
justification
et les décisions de l'ASS seront
proportionnées aux enjeux de sûreté
d'ici fin 2025 c'est l'engagement d'EDF
tous les réacteurs affectés devront être
contrôlés et éventuellement réparer
quand je dis tous les réacteurs c'est
l'ensemble du parc y compris les
réacteurs P4 les 8 réacteurs P4 et les
32 réacteurs de 900 MW qui semble
aujourd'hui peut pas affecter mais il
faudra bien évidemment vérifier cette
hypothèse
troisième point vu le caractère inédit
et les enjeux de sûreté le phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte suscite un
besoin naturel de transparence
d'information et de partage d'expérience
la présente table ronde en est
d'ailleurs parfaitement l'illustration
pendant toute la période d'investigation
et de dialogue technique avec EDF l'ASN
c'était forcé de garantir cette
information et la transparence du public
ainsi que l'échange d'expérience avec
ces homologues à l'étranger dès les
premiers échanges avec EDF en janvier
2022 l'ASN a mis en ligne un dossier
spécifique sur la problématique de
corrosion sous contrainte sur son site
internet consultable bien évidemment
partout dans lequel figure à ce jour
l'ensemble de ces courriers de demande
de ces prises de position ainsi que les
notes d'information qui ont été émises
sur le sujet
les divisions territoriales de l'ASM ont
participé aux réunions des commissions
locales d'information qui ont abordé ce
sujet pour leur faire part de l'état des
connaissances et du dialogue que nous
avions avec EDF de la même manière la SN
est intervenue lors des présentations
qui ont été faites par EDF lors des
réunions du haut-commité sur la
transparence et la sécurité nucléaire et
participera au prochain webinaire
organisé par l'ampli et les clients sur
ce sujet les groupes permanents
d'experts placés auprès de la SN ont été
tenues informés et ce sont prononcés sur
les avis émis par ont vu des avis émis
pardon de la SN sur la stratégie
proposée par EDF et les moyens de
contrôle qui ont été développés nous
avons réalisé 38 inspections sur le
sujet depuis le début de cette affaire
ou poursuivons de très près les
opérations les chantiers qui sont
réalisés par les prestataires
et les lettres de suite de ces
inspections sont toutes disponibles
également sur le site internet de la SN
nous avons mené plusieurs actions de
partage de connaissances et d'échanges
avec les autres régulateurs
internationaux soit dans le cadre des
instances européennes string wienera des
instances internationales comme l'INRA
et dans le cas des réunions bilatérales
que nous avons avec nos homologues à
l'étranger et je dois dire qu'il y a une
forte demande de connaissance
d'informations de la part nos homologues
qui s'agit de nos homologues européens
de nos homologues nord-américains
asiatiques et même l'Afrique du Sud qui
est équipée de réacteurs de conception
proche d'un concept français donc ce
sujet suscite un fort intérêt et de
nombreux régulateurs ont d'ores et déjà
demandé à leurs exploitants de réaliser
des contrôles sur leurs propres
installations
enfin je terminerai par un quatrième
point qui concerne les enseignements que
nous pouvons tirer à ce stade de cet
événement j'envoie trois principaux tout
d'abord au vu des découvertes faites je
pense qu'il faut d'abord en tirer un
enseignement de prudence la SN considère
que les connaissances sur le phénomène
de corrosion sous contrainte sont encore
évolutives et que le programme de
contrôle devra être adapté si les
contrôles ou les analyses mettez en
évidence des éléments nouveaux le
premier résultat de contrôle réalisé par
la technique de NDA améliorée montre que
des tailles de fissuration non
rencontrées dans la phase
d'investigation avec des coupes
pourraient être détecté et de même il
faut rester prudent sur les capacités
industrielles disponibles qui mobilise
des segments industriels déjà en tension
mais contrôleur non destructifs les
tuyauteurs les soudeurs et il convient
renforcer davantage
ses capacités industrielles pour pouvoir
faire face bien sûr à l'ampleur des
opérations de contrôle et de travaux qui
sont encore devant nous
le second enseignement et que dans une
démarche de défense en profondeur la
capacité des exploitants à aller voir
les choses auxquelles on ne s'attend pas
nécessairement doit être conforté doit
être entretenu c'est l'objet certes des
plans de maintenance préventive des
exploitants qui devront être complétés
au vu du retour d'expérience de cet
événement mais aussi de l'examen de
conformité détaillé que nous demandons
aux exploitants de réaliser lors des
visites décennales comme l'indiqué
Cédric Lewandowski c'est d'ailleurs à
l'occasion d'une visite décennale que le
phénomène a été découvert allez voir les
parties de l'installation que l'on ne
voit pas facilement en exploitation
normale par exemple des réseaux enterrés
des câbles électriques d'autres parties
de l'installation vérifiez que les a
priori sur la tenue des équipements sont
bien justifiés et utiliser les nouvelles
techniques de contrôle non
en 2013 la SN avait formulé un avis dans
ce sens dans le cadre du débat sur la
politique énergétique à l'époque dans
cet avis la SN soulignait l'importance
de disposer de marches suffisantes dans
le système électrique pour pouvoir faire
face à la nécessité de suspendre
simultanément pour des raisons de sûreté
le fonctionnement de plusieurs réacteurs
ce besoin a été réaffirmé à plusieurs
reprises notamment dans les rapports
annuels de la SF sur l'état de la sûreté
et lors des présentations de ces
rapports à l'OPEX notamment le rapport
de 2018 et le rapporte 2021 la situation
actuelle illustre la nécessité
impérative de restaurer des marges pour
la sûreté dans le futur mix énergétique
et dans les décisions qui sont reprises
en termes de dimensionnement des
capacités de production électrique
quelle qu'elle soit pour dans le cadre
de du mix énergétique à l'horizon 2050
voilà monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président ce que je Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires ce que je
vous souhaitez dire en propos liminaire
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires je suis
très heureux de pouvoir apporter un
éclairage complémentaire au compte-rendu
que vient de nous apporter les acteurs
institutionnels je voudrais commencer
par saluer le sérieux l'étendue la du
travail d'analyse technique qui a été
mené et résumé ici dont nous avons
notamment pu prendre connaissance en
groupe permanent d'experts même si je
regrette s'agissant d'un sujet
spécifiquement équipement sous pression
nucléaire qu'on y dispose pas pour des
raisons institutionnelles du même niveau
de mise en critique par l'IRSN que sur
d'autres dossiers de sûreté pour autant
je voudrais insister sur quelques
enseignements à tirer de cette situation
en commençant par
rappeler que au vu des résultats date
qui pointe l'apparition et le
développement rapide du phénomène
jusqu'à atteindre une zone de
compression qui a arrêté la propagation
de ces fissures et bien une dizaine de
réacteurs ont fonctionné depuis 15 à 20
ans avec des fissures non détectées sur
un circuit d'importance essentiel pour
la sûreté ce qui évidemment n'est pas
rien alors certes ces fissures semblent
s'être arrêté qui a une profondeur qui
permet
en tout cas de tenter de justifier leur
nom nocivité et aucune situation
d'accident n'a nécessité d'éprouver leur
robustesse en situation critique mais on
aurait aussi bien pu être confronté à
cela et
ce constat je pense doit nous conduire à
beaucoup de modestie concernant l'état
réel des réacteurs par rapport aux
hypothèses de sûreté le fameux sujet de
la de la conformité en l'occurrence un
point qui me semble important c'est que
si l'instruction technique c'est à juste
titre concentré sur la caractérisation
du phénomène sa compréhension et la
stratégie de gestion qui en découle on a
peu discuté en fait de la manière dont
ce risque a été correctement ou non pris
en compte à la conception
si on en croit les explications
techniques sur le fait que le phénomène
de stratification lié à l'allongement
des lignes soit le facteur déclenchant
on peut en déduire que si le risque de
corrosion une contrainte était bien
identifiées des dès l'origine il n'a pas
été maîtrisé à deux niveaux clés de la
défense en profondeur la conception et
la surveillance en particulier
il semble que si l'ensemble des
paramètres a apporté une qualification
correcte sur les réacteurs 900 mégawatts
de Westinghouse dont le modèle a été
importé en France voilà l'impact de
l'allongement de ces lignes n'a pas été
anticipé lors du passage au palier 1300
puis au Palli N4 au passage on peut
s'interroger sur la manière dont ce
point a été traité dans l'augmentation
des puissances de réacteurs conçus au
fil du temps par Westinghouse sur la
même base qui ne semble pas affecter par
le même problème au-delà de ce constat
ce qui m'inquiète dans cette situation
c'est qu'elle nous dit des choses de la
faible capacité prédictive des
propriétés mécaniques des équipements
sous pression nucléaire hors de leur
domaine qualifié
dans le domaine qualifié tout tout va
bien et on dispose d'une grande capacité
de caractérisation destructive des
propriétés de ces équipements qui nous
permet de qualifier un domaine de
dimensionnement mais on constate que la
multiplication des facteurs en jeu les
nuances d'acier les écarts de
composition les modes de soudage les
différentes contraintes auxquelles ces
équipements sont soumis et la complexité
des relations entre ces différents
facteurs rend visiblement difficile de
projeter les conséquences sur les
propriétés attendues de différents
écarts par rapport au domaine qualifié
on l'avait vu ça a été rappelé je crois
par Monsieur le vice-président tout à
l'heure sur la cuve de l'EPR ou un
nombre décès aussi important que pour la
qualification de l'ensemble des cuves du
parc actuel a été nécessaire pour
caractériser les propriétés du couvercle
et du fond de cuve se ségrégé on l'a vu
aussi sur le dossier du générateur de
vapeur de Fessenheim ou une pièce qui
avait été fabriqué de façon
explicitement non conforme aux procédé
initial
à fait l'objet après dépôt d'un dossier
justification par EDF d'une conclusion
positive et je me souviens encore que en
groupe permanent de nombreux experts ce
sont déclarés surpris par le
comportement étonnamment bon de cette
pièce en d'autres termes il n'était pas
en mesure de prélire correctement
l'impact des écarts constatés
cela veut dire que du point de vue de la
sûreté on est exposé
au risque que des écarts même minimes
dans les conditions de fabrication ou
d'exploitation de ces équipements sous
pression nucléaire conduisent à des
écarts potentiellement important de leur
comportement par rapport aux propriétés
attendues et ce point m'amène à deux
préoccupations
la première s'agissant du parc actuel
c'est que il faut s'interroger sur tous
les écarts de conformité repérés pouvoir
non repérer mais pour ceux qui sont
repérés je pense en particulier au
dossier de fabrication de Creusot forge
dont
une grande partie a fait l'objet des cas
et sur la manière dont les incertitudes
générés par ces écarts sont croisés dans
les démonstrations de sûreté avec
différents enjeux ces démonstrations
postulants au titre de la conformité
que les équipements
réagissent comme il est prévu mais c'est
études à mon sens ne sont pas enfin
c'est cette hypothèse d'écart n'est pas
suffisamment croisée lorsque il s'agit
des analyses de conformité des analyses
de vieillissement ou de celles sur la
tenue à des situations extrêmes menées
dans le cadre du retour d'expérience de
Fukushima j'avais sur ce point déjà
formulé dans le cadre du volet
conformité du quatrième examen décennale
des réacteurs 900 MW une proposition que
je renouvelle ici qui consiste vis-à-vis
de ce risque à engager une démarche de
type stress test
assistant à postuler selon une méthode
évidemment à définir des écarts non
détectés des propriétés mécaniques de
ces équipements et à tester la
robustesse de la démonstration de sûreté
à ses écarts l'autre point auquel se
constat
m'amène c'est de souligner face aux
incertitudes auxquelles on est confronté
la fragilité qu'introduit le principe
même d'exclusion de rupture puisque tout
problème constaté a posteriori après
application de ce principe affaibli
irréversiblement la défense en
profondeur
ce point a été
enfin cette excision de rupture a été
étendue par EDF lors de la conception de
le père de Flamanville avec le succès
que l'on sait on a pu observer les
problèmes des soudures du circuit
secondaire principal ou des piquage de
circuit auxiliaire sur sur le circuit
primaire et EDF souhaite à nouveau
appliquer de façon extensive
principe d'exclusion de rupture à la
conception de l'eperge je pense que les
difficultés
constatées dans dans ce dossier doivent
amener à beaucoup plus de prudence sur
ce point le deuxième volet que je
souhaite développer un peu plus
rapidement c'est la question des
problèmes d'arbitrage entre sûreté et
sécurité on le sait depuis longtemps la
forte dépendance du système électrique
français à un parc nucléaire standardisé
constitue sans négliger l'avantage que
constitue cette standardisation du point
de vue de la sûreté une véritable
fragilité du point de vue de la sécurité
électrique le président de l'ASN de
l'époque et monsieur dorosuke l'a
rappelé avait dès 2013 souligné dans le
débat national sur la transition
énergétique que le système électrique ne
disposait pas des marges nécessaires
pour faire face à l'indisponibilité pour
une raison de sûreté générique d'une
dizaine de réacteurs on sait qu'on a pas
fait grand chose depuis entre le retard
sur les renouvelables la France est le
seul pays à avoir raté objectif européen
en 2020 la faiblesse des actions
maîtrise de la demande et le frein à la
fermeture des réacteurs pour diversifier
et réduire cette dépendance et cet hiver
nous y sommes précisément au type de
situation que décrivait pierre Franck
chevet
cette situation elle nous expose en fait
mécaniquement à un arbitrage par nature
malsain entre eux sécurité électrique et
sur tes nucléaire qui se double dans le
contexte de crise énergétique que nous
connaissons d'une pression induite par
l'envolée des prix de marché que les
perspectives données par EDF avec une
prévision d'à peine 50% de facteurs de
charge du pacte nucléaire pour 2022 et à
peine plus pour 2023 ont évidemment
exacerbé EDF a beaucoup communiqué sur
une application volontaire et vertueuse
du principe de précaution lorsque les
premiers résultats ont conduit au
constat rappelé sur civo en arrêtant
préventivement les quatre réacteurs du
Palm 4 mais on peut constater que le
même principe de précaution n'a pas été
appliqué lorsque un problème a été
détecté sur un réacteur du palier pink 4
en lien et on peut clairement y voir le
poids de l'impact qu'aurait eu la même
application du principe de précaution
sur la sécurité électrique plus
largement on a vu me semble-t-il
l'évolution générale l'orientation
générale du dossier évoluer sous cette
pression des enjeux d'approvisionnement
électrique alors EDF a réalisé de
nombreuses opérations bien sûr ça a été
rappelé mais très vite l'opérateur c'est
engagé dans une démarche d'étalement des
contrôles priorisant certains réacteurs
pour mieux retarder l'examen des autres
et puis une fois que la SN a accepté cet
état allemand EDF appelé pour une mise
en œuvre rapide des réparations des
portions de circuit découpé avant même
que l'instruction technique est permis
de caractériser avec suffisamment
d'assurance les facteurs en jeu pour
s'assurer de la non reproduction de ce
problème
appelé par le gouvernement à produire
des signaux susceptibles je cite de
refroidir les marchés EDF a pris des
engagements très volontaristes sur le
redémarrage des réacteurs pour s'en
convaincre on peut observer que RTE dans
son analyse prévisionnelle sur le
passage de l'hiver 2022 2023 prévoit sur
la période de décembre à janvier en
hypothèse haute une disponibilité
moyenne du parc environ 10 GW inférieur
aux engagements pris par EDF et
globalement cette situation conduit
aujourd'hui à accélérer les réparations
en faisant appel ça a été lié également
à des soudeurs américains et en
relâchant les marges de prudence
habituellement appliquées vis-à-vis des
limites réglementaires de
radioprotection des travailleurs
on arrive maintenant avec le cas de
quatre noms 1 qui a été mentionné
rapidement par l'IRSN à la fin de sa son
intervention à une nouvelle étape ou EDF
cherche à justifier plutôt qu'une
découpe et réparation immédiate sur une
voire deux fissures 6 suspecter si j'ai
bien compris le report de ces opérations
à un nouvel arrêt programmé après
l'hiver une telle stratégie si elle
devait être validée par une décision à
venir de la SN ne reposerait clairement
pas sur un raisonnement ne faisant
intervenir que la sûreté mais sur une
forme de dérogation motivée par les
enjeux de sécurité électrique et cette
dérive globalement me semble dangereuse
elle appelle en conclusion à se poser la
question des options pour rendre le
système électrique moins dépendant à la
disponibilité à tout prix du park
nucléaire ça tombe bien c'est en partie
l'objet du débat public sur les nouveaux
EPERS qui s'ouvrent aujourd'hui et de la
concertation ouverte par le gouvernement
sur l'avenir du système énergétique elle
également et c'est une préoccupation
fortement exprimée par le groupe
permanent à l'élaboration par EDF d'une
stratégie plus pérenne de traitement de
cette situation que la méthode de
détection réparation mise en oeuvre dans
une vision de court terme pour l'instant
et puis je finirai par évoquer la
question de la transparence puisque ce
point a été mentionné à plusieurs
reprises je voudrais simplement rappeler
ici que celle-ci ne s'arrête pas à
mettre à la disposition du public
l'information synthétique que
l'exploitant ou l'Autorité estime
nécessaire mais elle doit permettre
l'accès du public à toute l'information
non légitimement couverte par les
différents secrets on en reste à mon
sens pour l'instant très loin dans ce
dossier je vous remercie merci de ces
questions et du temps que vous consacrez
à ce sujet qui est effectivement tout à
fait fondamental je voudrais quand même
redire ce que j'ai dit en conclusion
tout à l'heure
qui est tout à fait clair il n'y a pas
d'arbitrage entre la sûreté et la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
la sûreté est une priorité absolue si
nous avons la moindre conviction
technique ou scientifique qu'un réacteur
se trouve en difficulté nous l'arrêtons
et c'est ce que nous avons démontré très
clairement dans cette crise puisque je
vous rappelle que nous avons pris la
décision d'arrêter une douzaine de
réacteurs alors même que nous étions en
plein hiver donc à un moment où
l'approvisionnement en électricité est
évidemment une question cruciale pour
nos concitoyens donc sur ce terrain là
je récuse le mot d'arbitrage nous serons
toujours d'abord et avant tout au
service de la sûreté et bien évidemment
le second point est bien celui de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement auquel on
est très attentif plus que plus que
jamais dans ce temps de crise
énergétique
mais je tiens à le redire puisqu'il est
absolument fondamental et il nous a
amené à prendre des décisions
très radical vous le savez
deuxième deuxième remarque qui répond à
quelques-unes des questions qui ont été
posées ou évoqués pourquoi une partie du
parc pourquoi
toutes ces questions sont légitimes je
vous ai dit pour ceux qui nous concerne
nos premières convictions mais avec
humilité c'est à dire qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de travail
y compris de recherche et développement
pour être parfaitement certain d'aboutir
à un consensus scientifique et technique
vue d'EDF la prépondérance le facteur
prépondérant de la création de cette
corrosion sous contrainte c'est bien le
design des lignes
je dis bien que ce n'est pas
nécessairement partagé mais vu de nous
c'est le design des lignes or au regard
de votre interpellation les lignes sont
de plus en plus complexes avec le temps
elles sont plus complexes dans le
dernier palier du N4 que dans le 1300
mégawatts et plus complexe dans le 1300
MW que dans le palier 900 MW ce qui veut
de nous est sans doute un élément
d'explication mais il y en a d'autres
j'ai évoqué le sujet de l'oxygène qui a
été évoqué aussi par l'IRSN il va
falloir travailler sur ce plan là et on
va mener un certain nombre d'expertises
la question de la température est
évidemment aussi très importante
et également des typologies de soudure
peut-être à partir desquels on détecte
ce défaut donc tous ces éléments là sont
encore en partie sur la table mais la
prépondérance des lignes vu de nous
conduit à l'explication du fait que oui
nous
bâtiment que le palier
900 mégawatts donc les 32 réacteurs ne
sont pas ou peu affectés par la
corrosion sous contrainte a priori mais
vous avez entendu le hoope donc par
rapport je le dis aussi par rapport à
l'idée qu'il n'y aurait pas de corrosion
sous contrainte sur le païen 900
mégawatts
certainement une affirmation que je ne
partage pas nous avons du travail à
réaliser sur le sujet et nous avons pris
l'engagement vis-à-vis de l'autorité sur
tes nucléaires cela a été rappelé par le
président de roduc du fait que nous
allions contrôler
toutes ces lignes de tous nos réacteurs
y compris 900 MW d'ici à la fin 2025
simplement nous avons priorisé sur notre
travail sur les réacteurs qui sont vus
de nous les plus potentiellement
affectés c'est ce qu'on appelle le P
prime 4 les 12 réacteurs que j'ai
évoqués tout à l'heure et dans le
président de roduc a redit à l'instant
que nous avions pris l'engagement de les
contrôler avant l'ami 2023 voilà c'est
simplement que il y a sans doute un
ordre de priorité qui est lié vu de nous
à la prépondérance des lignes mais bien
sûr que beaucoup de travail de
compréhension reste à faire ce qui me
mène à l'autre sujet qui est tout à fait
fondamental vous l'avez évoqué c'est la
vitesse de propagation des fissures
aujourd'hui nos experts arrivent à une
espèce de vitesse enveloppe de une
propagation de 0,5 mm
par an
cette donnée là n'est pas consensuelle
aujourd'hui elle doit faire encore
l'objet d'un très grand nombre de
travaux sur lesquels nous sommes
concentrés les uns et les autres
évidemment qu'elle est tout à fait
fondamentale pardon tout à fait
fondamental pour avoir la bonne
compréhension de main de la maîtrise de
ce de ce process
troisième remarque le manchonage
loverlay pour reprendre le mot consacré
dans ce domaine là pourquoi est-ce que
nous ne l'avons pas retenu monsieur
sénateur mais tout simplement parce que
c'est un projet qui n'est pas qualifié
dans notre réglementation française
donc nous ne l'excluons absolument pas
c'est ce que j'ai dit peut-être un peu
rapidement tout à l'heure mais
aujourd'hui il n'est pas qualifié or
qualifié
un process de cette ampleur là on parle
bien de cirque auxiliaire au circuit
primaire demande plusieurs mois pour ne
pas dire plusieurs années d'instruction
pour pouvoir aboutir et donc il nous
était impossible de mettre en place
cette technique là au regard de notre
enjeu qui reste bien et c'est le second
la sécurité d'approvisionnement là
évidemment notre objectif c'était bien
de remettre des réacteurs en marche sur
le réseau pour autant nous avons
parfaitement entendu et notamment j'ai
évoqué les experts internationaux que
nous avions invité à Paris notamment de
pri d'ailleurs les Américains qui nous
ont dit mais c'est peut-être un sujet
que vous devriez remettre sur la table
au vu de cette crise c'est un sujet
qu'il faut étudier et donc oui je l'ai
annoncé devant vous nous allons étudier
ce
cette question là de l'overlay et nous
allons bien évidemment engager un
dialogue avec la SN sur la question ça
paraît absolument fondamental voilà ce
que je peux répondre oui sur la présence
de soudeur d'usineurs étranger je
voudrais être très clair sur deux points
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de confusion là
aussi
premier sujet
nous avions besoin le plus rapidement
possible de fonderie en capacité de nous
préparer des lingots d'inoxes de qualité
et ensuite de les forger en fonction de
nos spécifications
c'est évidemment une tristesse pour nous
que de ne pas avoir trouvé dans les
temps impartis de fondeur français en
capacité de faire ce travail et donc je
suis très reconnaissant à deux fondeurs
d'Italie du Nord d'avoir répondu présent
et de nous fournir aujourd'hui travail
de très grande qualité
du côté des soudeurs et des usinaires
des tuyauteurs nous avons et le sujet
est parfaitement connu tout le milieu
industriel un déficit très clair dans
cette profession nous avons besoin de
beaucoup de soudeurs de tuyauteurs et
d'usineurs dans notre pays ça c'est
clair c'est la raison pour laquelle le
sujet a été évoqué nous avons par
exemple recréé une école de métier en ce
moment à Cherbourg sur le soudage et il
y en aura d'autres c'est une évidence
parce que nous avons besoin de ces
compétences là donc premier point il y a
un déficit industriel qui ne concerne
pas que l'industrie nucléaire mais qui
est beaucoup plus large le deuxième
point nous l'avons évoqué rapidement
mais qui est très important c'est que ce
sont des travaux qui se font dans un
environnement radioactif avec des
dosimétries importantes et donc il
reçoit que nous respectons non seulement
la réglementation mais en vérité on
prend même une marge par rapport à la
réglementation de la dose acceptable
pour chacun des salariés quels qu'ils
soient EDF ou prestataire qui viennent
travailler évidemment auprès de nous et
il est clair qu'à partir d'un certain
nombre d'heures de travail et bien tout
simplement pour éviter de dépasser la
dose prescrite ces personnes là doivent
se retirer ce qui est parfaitement clair
nous demande donc une rotation de
personnel tout à fait considérable c'est
à ce titre-là qu'un certain nombre des
groupements qui travaillent avec nous et
que j'ai salué tout à l'heure on fait
appel à une main d'oeuvre étrangère de
grande qualité alors on a parlé beaucoup
d'Américains ou de Canadiens mais on a
aussi beaucoup d'Européens qui sont
venus rapidement à notre à notre secours
pour conforter le travail que nous
souhaitions mener et que nous
souhaitions mener rapidement voilà
pourquoi nous avons fait appel à ce
monde là mais en vérité il représente de
toute façon cette main d'oeuvre
étrangère moins de 10% des effectifs qui
travaillent à nos côtés notamment en
termes de soudeur de tuyauteur Étienne
est-ce que j'ai oublié ou utiliser
quelque chose peut-être simplement un
point concernant la question de l'âme la
sénatrice sur le l'évolution des
matériaux entre les différentes
générations de réacteurs nous sommes
toujours restés sur les mêmes matériaux
un détail près mais qui n'intervient pas
dans le cadre de la CSC ce sont toujours
des aciers inoxydables austenitiques qui
ont des propriétés intéressantes de
résistance et de capacité à être soudés
donc le l'évolution des matériaux n'est
pas une explication aujourd'hui qui est
retenue dans le cadre de la CSC et
d'autre part nous n'avons pas non plus
constaté dans nos analyses de déviation
sur les matériaux utilisés par rapport
aux spécifications tous les matériaux
étaient conformes
peut-être un point sur la temporalité
que vous avez évoqué en fait la question
de la temporalité c'est la question de
la périodicité des contrôles de
maintenance or la bien avoir en tête que
la maintenance c'est quelque chose qui
est revisité en permanence en fonction
du retour d'expérience en fonction de ce
qu'on constate sur sur nos installations
avec parfois des allègements si on voit
que la maintenance était où les
contrôles étaient sur abondance ça peut
arriver aussi ou parfois des
approfondissements et là on est vraiment
dans ce cas là si vous constatez que
vous êtes sur une situation qui était
inattendue qui nécessite un renforcement
des opérations de maintenance donc
concrètement sur à la suite de la
découverte de corrosion sous contrainte
nous allons évidemment élaborer un
programme de contrôle adapté à la
surveillance de cette maladie entre
guillemets que nous avons découverte ici
et dont la périodicité va être adaptée à
ce que l'on comprend de la cinétique du
phénomène et de son évolution et ça
c'est encore un sujet en cours d'études
sur le mentionnage loverlay donc il est
lancé EDF souhaité exploré cette piste
et que la SN nous l'expertise aurions un
des sujets qui se rapprolement compliqué
c'est le contrôle des soudures si vous
voulez si vous les entourez c'est plus
compliqué entre les donc ce sera un
sujet important dans un éventuel échange
technique sur les conséquences sur les
futurs chantiers et sur l'avenir donc un
juge de paix c'est vraiment le moyen de
contrôle d'ailleurs ça a des activités
sur lequel IRSN et une R&D c'est les
moyens de contrôle au-delà de ce système
là sur les installations qui existent un
point essentiel ça c'est le premier
point l'oxygène alors avec EDF on est
d'accord sur la stratification n'est pas
pour l'instant on n'a pas convaincu EDF
de l'importance de l'oxygène mais je ne
désespère pas d'y arriver et le dernier
point c'est que sur le père et le PR2
les soudures sont à rasées ce qui est un
facteur favorable d'une part pour
l'apparition des soudures et surtout
pour le contrôle
c'est le député Alexandre ça va tout
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour vos retours et je tiens à
vous féliciter pour la rapidité et la
qualité de traitement de ces incidents
qui doit rassurer les Français notamment
sur votre capacité à gérer des crises
qui comme vous l'avez souligné était
inédite
moi je me pose tout de même une question
c'est y-a-t-il un vrai risque ou
avons-nous fait de l'excès de zèle dans
cette question de crise à cause
notamment de l'hypermédiatisation des
sujets nucléaires et de la pression que
que vous ressentez à ce titre
qu'en est-il chez nos voisins parce que
donc voilà moi je sais à peu près
comment cela fonctionne l'ASN fait une
analyse rajoute une marge et ensuite
chez EDF ou les acteurs travaillant dans
les centrales nucléaires pour que les
contrôles avec la SN se passent bien
vous rajoutez également une marche donc
n'en faisons-nous pas trop ce qui
nuirait à notre productivité en
transformant finalement cet excès de
sécurité en une entrave à notre capacité
au niveau au niveau du nucléaire et donc
qu'en est-il chez nos voisins est-ce que
nous sommes les plus sécuritaires ou
est-ce que il me semble qu'aux
États-Unis ils sont un peu plus souples
de ce point de vue là et donc quel est
votre avis sur ce sujet
et pourquoi cette question parce que
dans les documents que vous avez mis à
notre disposition vous avez expliqué que
ces fissures représentées 10% de
l'épaisseur du tuyau vous avez mentionné
l'IRSN la notion de défaut critique donc
justement la question se pose c'est
est-ce qu'il fallait
du fait que vous expliquez que la
propagation de ces fissures augmente de
quelques millimètres par an enfin de
l'ordre du millimètre par an est-ce
qu'il était nécessaire d'arrêter un
tiers de la production du nucléaire
français pour faire face
à cette à cette incidence ou est-ce que
on aurait pu imaginer de lisser
justement cette cette réparation cette
gestion de crise pour limiter ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui avec
avec la crise la crise énergétique et je
terminerai mon propos
au niveau de la présence de l'Institut
Negawatt donc j'en mets pas en question
du tout
l'existence et
de votre association ou de ce que vous
apportez au débat parce que je pense que
il faut du pour et du contre pour
prendre les meilleures solutions pour
les Français mais je me pose la question
de la présence de cette institut au sein
de cette audition sur ce sujet merci
j'ai pu avoir beaucoup de questions à
poser mes collègues ayant abordé
quasiment tous les thèmes
je voudrais relayer un petit peu la
dernière intervention effectivement par
rapport à l'expérience étrangère
est-ce que nos contrôles sont plus
pointus ou est-ce que nos méthodes
nous soudures nos tuyaux ne sont pas les
mêmes qu'à l'étranger
parce qu'on sait bien qu'en France et en
tout cas sous la houlette de la SN et
les RSN on a une grande fiabilité de la
sûreté
mais d'essayer de comprendre mais vous
nous l'avez bien dit
que c'était pas évident de savoir
qu'elle était la raison entre le métal
entre les usages et autres et j'ai
simplement une question qui me qui
demeure mais c'est pour
c'est pour Monsieur Lewandowski vous
aviez vous avez parlé de la relecture a
posteriori des contrôles sur 10 ans
est-ce que ça vous a révélé quelque
chose et est-ce que c'est une pratique
habituelle
moi je me souviens d'audition ici sur
des problèmes de soudure des cuves c'est
pas les premières fois que sur des
centrales nucléaires
on se penche sur le problème des
soudures
et est-ce que cette relecture est
habituelle et est-ce qu'elle nous a
est-ce qu'elle vous a en tout cas
auparavant apporté quelque chose merci
et puis particulièrement aussi à
l'office pour
développer ces deux transparence dans le
nucléaire attendez besoin parce que tout
repose sur la confiance si vous
permettez je vais aller un peu plus loin
est-ce en tant que membre de la
commission défense est-ce que les
installations embarquées de nomade notre
marine et scénaris Charles de Gaulle
connaisse les mêmes problèmes sachant
que c'est pas les mêmes géométrie du
tout et puis si ils connaissent pas ce
type de problème à ma connaissance c'est
le cas
quelles leçons pourront nous tirer pour
vous installations et puis surtout le
développement des petits unités
nucléaires que le Président de la
République a évoqué comment elle peut
trouver sa place dans le mix énergétique
et que vous développez à EDF
un petit peu du cadre de la corrosion
sous contrainte mais ce sera intéressant
quand même d'avoir une perspective vous
avez raison d'en profiter de leur
présence
peut-être si vous voulez reprendre la
parole
merci à nouveau pour pour toutes ces
questions peut-être commencer par la
question de madame la sénatrice sur la
relecture apostériori tout simplement à
partir du moment où nous étions
confrontés sur six vaut 1 à un phénomène
que nous ne comprenions pas
qui n'était pas conforme à ce que nous
disposons dans notre
référentiel
il nous a paru intéressant d'aller
fouiller dans l'ensemble de nos archives
pour essayer de retrouver des notations
et on appelle ça nous des indications
des signaux éventuellement atypiques qui
auraient pu être éventuellement
signifier dans toutes les années
précédentes lors des visites décennales
sur l'ensemble du parc est-ce que nous
le faisons régulièrement oui est-ce que
nous le faisons avec cette ampleur non
effectivement la particularité c'est
qu'on est allé voir l'ensemble c'est des
dizaines de gens qui ont été mobilisés
pour aller Reda tailler l'ensemble de
nos archives est-ce que ça a été utile
oui bien sûr puisque c'est justement ce
travail documentaire qui nous a permis
de définir très précisément les sept
réacteurs complémentaires aux quatre
premiers et à panli 1 que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure pourquoi parce que sur
ces 7 réacteurs nous faire nous en dit
nous estimons que les notes prises les
indications qui ont pu être vues à
l'époque
ressemblent à ce que nous pensons voir
si vous donc à nouveau il n'y a pas de
vérité révélée nous sommes à l'époque
dans un moment où il faut bien prendre
les éléments dont on peut disposer face
à un phénomène inconnu mais ça a été
effectivement extraordinairement utile
et ça renvoie à nouveau accessoirement à
la qualité des archives de la de la
maison et la manière dont la traçabilité
de l'ensemble de nos outils et non
seulement nécessaire mais vraiment
extrêmement
utile et nous a permis d'apporter ces
éléments donc grâce soit rendu à tous
ceux qui contribuent à cette traçabilité
sur la question très précise des
installations
embarquées du côté de la défense sachez
que nous avons évidemment des contacts
réguliers qu'ils ont été informés de
l'ensemble de nos travaux maintenant je
permettrai de vous renvoyer à eux comme
vous êtes à la commission
iguane pour leur poser la question mais
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
très très différente donc difficilement
comparable mais le travail a été fait
d'échange sur le plan sur le plan
technique soyez-en assurés peut-être
Étienne sur la dimension internationale
qui a pu être évoqué le partage oui de
depuis le début de la crise corrosion
sous contrainte j'ai des échanges avec
mes homologues plus particulièrement
avec mes homologues en Europe d'ailleurs
sur le sujet que j'ai tenu régulièrement
informé nous avons des réunions qui me
permettent de faire cela
je les ai tenu informé à la fois de
l'évolution de la crise chez nous mais
aussi de nos premières conclusions
puisque ça ça leur permet aussi de
nourrir leur propre réflexion je pense
en particulier à ce que nous avons
détecté sur l'influence du design qui
peut les réinterroger les amener à
prioriser et puis tout récemment le j'ai
eu l'occasion de le faire cette fois-ci
avec une dans le cadre du d'une réunion
mondiale des exploitants ou donc les
organisateurs avaient sollicité EDF pour
faire une présentation complète sur le
dans le domaine de la corrosion sous
contrainte donc il y a bien un partage
entre les différents exploitants chacun
traitant le sujet dans le cadre
réglementaire qui est le sien et qui
conditionne une grande partie de la
suite des événements
par rapport à la question de l'excès de
zèle que vous avez posé monsieur le
député c'est une question
très clairement légitime mais nous avons
eu le sentiment au contraire d'être les
plus pragmatiques
possibles avec toujours un seul principe
pardon de le répéter mais qui est que la
priorité absolue est bien celle de la
sûreté à partir de là quand vous êtes
confronté un défaut que vous ne
connaissez pas qui est dans un circuit
auxiliaire du circuit primaire
c'est-à-dire dans un lieu qui est
évidemment très particulier dans une
centrale nucléaire la moindre des choses
c'est de prendre le maximum de
précaution et nous pensons avoir eu
raison de le faire avec le recul du
temps pas simplement au nom du principe
mais tout simplement parce que la la
taille et la profondeur d'un certain
nombre de fissures notamment quand elles
sont sur l'ensemble de la circonférence
renvoie à des analyses de sûreté qui
doivent être très clairement sur le
métier c'est le travail que nous sommes
en train de faire tous ensemble avec
avec la SN et l'IRSN donc non nous
n'avons pas eu le sentiment d'en avoir
trop fait au contraire pense qu'on a
essayé de mesurer nos efforts au regard
de la politique de sûreté telle qu'elle
nous apparaissait absolument essentielle
par ailleurs la réglementation française
et qui est de bonne aloi dit que sur ces
tuyauterie là on admet pas de défaut on
admet pas d'Alea et ça paraît aussi
assez naturel que de pouvoir garantir à
nos concitoyens que lorsqu'on approche
le circuit primaire on a affaire à un
matériel qui est dans un état
d'exception je tiens à vous rassurer un
tiers de l'appareil de production n'a
pas été arrêté du fait de la corrosion
sous contrainte il se trouve qu'en ce
moment
c'est ainsi les sujets se cumulent nous
avons en parallèle un programme
considérable qui est le grand carénage
qui nous permet de passer de 40 à 50 ans
comme vous savez
de vie pour une partie du de nos
rectangles en tout cas le 900 mégawatts
et que ces travaux conduisent
effectivement l'arrêt durable près de 6
mois de
d'un grand nombre de nos réacteurs
justement du fait de ce grand carénage
qui a commencé maintenant depuis deux
ans donc c'est bien le cumul de travaux
tout à fait considérable sur le grand
carénage qu'on appelle post Fukushima
donc les vd4 du 900 mégawatts plus la
corrosion sous contrainte qui nous a
amené à cette perte de productible qui
est tout à fait considérable il s'agit
certainement pas de de la relativiser
mais qui nous conduit à prévoir
effectivement cette année un productible
de l'ordre 280 à 300 TW pour l'année
sur la question des SMS peut-être très
rapidement puisque c'était votre
question un peu indépendante de notre
sujet
nous pensons au regard de l'ensemble des
analyses internationales de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie et de
l'Union européenne qui toute convergent
pour dire que l'électricité va connaître
des courbes de croissance tout à fait
considérable notamment du fait de
nouveaux usages dans les années qui
viennent que nous aurons besoin de toute
l'électricité des carbonées possible
donc on l'a dit bien sûr dans le domaine
renouvelable c'est pas notre sujet
aujourd'hui nous le pensons également
dans le domaine nucléaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle EDF propose de
prolonger la durée de vie de ces
centrales et il travaille je n'évoquais
à l'instant c'est le grand carénage
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
déposé un dossier auprès du gouvernement
au printemps 2021 proposant la
construction de 6 OPR 2 vous le savez
également mais également nous pensons
que les petits réacteurs les SMS
pourraient être un complément
extrêmement utile à beaucoup à
l'international mais y compris chez nous
pour un certain nombre d'usages dans les
années qui viennent nous avons créé un
consortium avec technique atome avec le
CEA avec
naval group pour concevoir un réacteur
de 170 MW électrique et nous espérons
proposer un design au gouvernement de ce
sms qu'on a appelé new Award en 2023
donc une course est lancée autour des
SMS qui nous paraissent effectivement
une voie d'avenir extrêmement
intéressante pour le nucléaire français
merci monsieur le Président oui moi je
voudrais revenir sur sur la question à
la fois de la
du plan d'investigation et essayer
d'apporter une réponse monsieur député à
votre question sur l'excès Deux Alpes
potentiel je crois que nous avons essayé
les uns et les autres de bien expliquer
à la fois le caractère totalment inédit
par rapport au parc mondial de la
découverte de corrosion sous contrainte
mais également le fait que EDF ne
disposait d'aucun moyen au moment où la
découverte a été faite pour caractériser
la taille de la fissuration autrement
dit nous étions en aveugle pendant à peu
près un semestre il était même pas
envisageable d'imaginer de demander à
EDF de justifier le maintien en service
des réacteurs puisqu'on ne savait pas
quels étaient les circuits affectés
quels étaient les tailles de défauts
potentiels et qu'elles étaient les
marges par rapport un risque de rupture
on savait simplement que ce phénomène
était présent sur des circuits non Isola
par rapport au circuit primaire et comme
je l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire
qu'en cas de rupture nous étions face à
un accident nucléaire donc pendant 6
mois nous sommes en aveugle et il était
absolument indispensable de mener les
investigations qui nécessitaient des
découpes puisque pas de moyens de
contrôle pour pouvoir expertiser
identifier quel était l'ampleur des des
dégâts si je peux prendre ce terme sur
l'ensemble du parc nucléaire d'où la
période d'investigation qui a été menée
nous sommes dans une deuxième phase à
partir de maintenant sommes dans une
phase où grâce au travail
d'investigation en profondeur qui a été
menée un ordre de priorité a été défini
que nous avons reconnu comme étant
acceptable au regard des justifications
sur les facteurs prépondérants de
développement de cette corrosion liée
aux géométrie des lignes et par rapport
à la question qui est posée tout à
l'heure mais pourquoi donc cette
situation ne sait pas trouver sur
d'autres types de réacteurs voire à
l'étranger c'est parce que effectivement
la géométrie des lignes des lignes en
question à évolué à travers le temps
avec le palier très simple puis à
travers le palier de 4 il n'y a à ma
connaissance pas de réacteur dans le
monde avec des géométries de ligne
comparables à celle que nous avons sur
le réacteur très simple le recteur N4 il
faut le vérifier mais aujourd'hui c'est
très différent les réacteurs les plus
répandus à eau sous pression sont dans
des conceptions comparables au réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts que nous avons en
France qui sont de conception
Westinghouse et ce sont les réacteurs
les plus anciens qui ont 40 ans et qui
ne sont pas ou peu affectés donc on voit
bien ce n'est pas un phénomène lié au
vieillissement la question n'est pas de
savoir si parce que les installations
vieillissent ce phénomène de se
développer non il peut se développer
rapidement sur des réacteurs qui sont
relativement récents les réacteurs N4
ont 20 ans donc voyez-vous nous étions
dans une première période dans un peu
dans le noir et il fallait absolument
que ce plan soit développé écran
parallèle une technique de contrôle non
destructive qui reste encore à améliorer
et à qualifier puisse nous permettre de
mettre en œuvre le la stratégie qui a
été développée par des c'est la phase
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons nous
sommes maintenant en mesure d'accepter
la priorisation qui a été proposée par
EDF et bien évidemment comme je l'ai dit
également en fonction des résultats qui
seront découverts liés à ces
investigations peut-être cette stratégie
de contrôle et vous le rappelle c'est
encore possible nous sommes loin d'avoir
fait le tour de cette question
quelle réaction par rapport à ce
phénomène à l'étranger comme je l'ai dit
nous avons présenté à nos homologues
étrangers la situation et je peux vous
dire qu'aucun d'entre eux qu'aucun
d'entre eux n'a estimé que nous avions
fait collectivement EDF qui a pris
toutes les décisions mises à l'arrêt et
la SN d'excès de l ils auraient fait la
même chose dans leur pays si les
fissurations n'ont pas de 10%, mais
parfois du quart de l'épaisseur avait
été découvertes on est parfois avec
quasiment aucune marge par rapport à la
taille du défaut critique qui pourrait
entraîner en cas de sollicitations du
réseau du circuit pardon d'injection de
sécurité une rupture hop ça a été bien
n'est présenté au début on est dans un
circuit qui est d'une certaine manière
passif au démarrage on ne l'utilise pas
en fonctionnement normal de
l'installation en revanche si on en a
besoin pour faire face à une brèche
primaire il faut pouvoir injecter de
manière rapide une quantité importante
d'eau pour pouvoir alimenter le cœur et
l'activation du coeur
si dans une telle hypothèse parce que il
y aurait forcément un choc froid il y
aurait
une amenée rapide d'eau à une
température plus froide que la
température du cœur la se chauffe froide
avec une tuyauterie qui comporterait des
fissurations
de l'épaisseur pourrait se rompre donc
c'est un véritable sujet sérieux
important en termes de sûreté et il faut
distinguer dans notre analyse les deux
phases les premiers six mois qui étaient
nécessaires en termes d'investigation
qui ont fait l'objet également de la
part d'EDF de justification en termes de
tenue mécanique en termes ça a été dit
par l'IRSN de justification de capacité
à replier le réacteur en cas de rupture
de deux ligneries avec un certain nombre
de marge de d'aggravants pardon
permettant de le justifier et également
des mesures de surveillance en
exploitation c'est ce bouquet cet
ensemble de justification qui ont été
fournies par EDF au cours du premier
semestre qui nous se conduit à accepter
le maintien en service des réacteurs
sans excès prudence ensuite ce que je
voudrais dire par rapport à la question
du de du débat entre
potentiel entre sécurité et
d'alimentation électrique et sûreté à
aucun moment à aucun moment nous n'avons
pris de décision nous n'avons validé des
propositions d'EDF en prenant en compte
le risque de d'alimentation électrique
nous avons pris des décisions
proportionnées qui ont été toutes
justifiées par des ondes de sûreté si
EDF n'avait pas pris les décisions
qu'ils ont prises et si nous avions
estimé qu'il y avait un enjeu de sûreté
nous aurions demandé à l'exploitant de
mettre à l'arrêt les réacteurs ça me
paraît tout à fait clair notre position
sont proportionnées aux enjeux mais
elles ne sont à aucun moment en
situation d'arbitrage et je pense
collectivement mettre en débat la
question de arbitrage entre la sécurité
d'alimentation électrique et la sûreté
nucléaire ne serait absolument pas une
position qui serait tenable qui serait
acceptable parce que la sûreté doit être
considérée comme étant un bien commun et
aucun acteur qu'il s'agisse du
gouvernement de l'expattant ou des
publics ne peut soutenir l'idée qu'il
faille faire un arbitrage entre les deux
parce que c'est une question de remise
en cause totale du contrôle de la
confiance pardon dans le contrôle du
nucléaire si on allait dans cette voie
ceux de La Londe
moi aussi je voudrais rebondir sur
l'interrogation je ne prends
l'interventions comme une interrogation
sur l'éventuelles excès de zèle de nos
partenaires pour vous signaler que je me
félicite de la réponse qui est apportée
par Monsieur Lewandowski au titre de DF
parce que je me souviens qu'il y a
quelques années j'avais été invité avec
les mêmes personnes non pas en nom mais
en structure représentée par la
commission de l'Assemblée nationale sur
une hépatite n'y avait-il pas eu un
excès de zèle sur le plan économique de
la décision prise par le président
chevet à l'époque de faire arrêter en
pleine période d'hiver des installations
nucléaires et la question était posée
par EDF
je ne me rappelais plus le nom de celui
qui représentait monsieur Lewandowski et
nous avions été unanime à dire que non
que ces contrôles étaient nécessaires et
comme vous les députés nous avaient posé
la question mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
chie en France alors que c'est pas fait
aux États-Unis ailleurs
mais effectivement pourquoi sur ce n'est
pas fait aux États-Unis et ailleurs et
on a rebondi sur la question qu'un
accident nucléaire avant Fukushima ça ne
pouvait pas arriver est-ce que vous êtes
sûr que demain un accident nucléaire
n'arrivera pas dans notre pays et si
l'interrogation que je prends comme tel
et j'espère que ce n'est pas au fond de
vous-même ce que vous souhaiteriez que
nous ayons un expert public à un
exploitant à
responsable à gendarme de la sûreté
ferme les yeux et n'exige pas cela je je
suis je ne vous provoque pas mais si si
tel était éventuellement votre question
est-ce que vous seriez à ce moment-là à
ma question à même d'assumer la
responsabilité et votre culpabilité
d'avoir laissé passer un accident donc
je suis persuadé que vous avez des mêmes
interrogations que nous pour savoir si
on en fait pas trop si on en fait pas
assez mais de faire en sorte que on
fasse tout ce qui est nécessaire de
faire pour que la sûreté soit maintenue
de se dégrade pas et se développe et je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord
mais je crois que notamment au vu des
propos qu'adules le président de l'ASN
la réponse a déjà été donnée avec cette
garantie qu'on peut avoir et notamment
en terme de prévention à la sûreté
nucléaire c'est le député
je tenais juste à proposer légèrement
mes propos
en fait j'ai mal peut-être mal posé ma
question
cette question là n'était pas forcément
axée sur la gestion de crise qui avait
eu parce que j'ai travaillé dans
l'industrie je sais comment ça marche de
ce point de vue là mais c'était plus
également plus général pas forcément sur
ce sujet là si
cette sécurité qui peut paraître
excessive ou non qui est justifié ou non
n'entrave pas notre productivité et
enfin voilà vous avez vous avez très
bien compris merci
monsieur Marignac oui merci monsieur le
Président quelques quelques commentaires
courts d'abord sur cette question de
d'un arbitrage entre sûreté et sécurité
moi je maintiens que de façon implicite
il s'applique aujourd'hui la SN
d'ailleurs a par le passé dans certaines
décisions pas celles qui concerne ce
dossier fait état dans ses considérants
de l'impératif de sécurité électrique et
quand monsieur leswandowski dit que la
sûreté est une priorité absolue certes
ça ne veut pas dire que la sûreté est un
critère absolu on relativise en
permanence on proportionne comme vient
de le dire monsieur le président de
l'ASN les décisions et actuellement je
considère qu'elles sont proportionnées
en ayant en tête la pression qui exerce
la sécurité électrique et des propos
comme ceux récents du ministre de
l'économie appelant à ce que EDF
redémarre à tout prix
ces réacteurs avant l'hiver